la chronique de l'écho avec claire
cambier bonsoir clair c'est la semaine
de l'industrie dont vous allez nous
parler notamment ce soir
et oui cette semaine est marquée par de
nombreux événements dans le monde
économique
on a annoncé mardi la semaine de
l'artisanat mais c'est également la
semaine de l'industrie et la semaine a
créé son entreprise crée son entreprise
est une initiative lancée par la bce
le réseau national d'appui aux
entreprises michel et là vous êtes
directeur de la bg yvelines bonsoir on
vous retrouve à la fin de cette
chronique pour en parler avant cela donc
on va discuter de la semaine de
l'industrie
un événement national repris bien
évidemment par les acteurs des yvelines
son but est de mettre un coup de
projecteur sur ce secteur est de faire
découvrir ces métiers pas toujours connu
du grand public
dans ce département cela concerne 10 9%
portant de l'activité principalement
dans l'aéronautique l'informatique et
l'automobile magali la faune bonjour
joue le travail est justement dans
l'automobile vous faites donc partie des
40 2,2 pour cent des effectifs
industriels du département vous êtes
chef de projet au technocentre renault
vous êtes également marraine dans
l'association elles bougent c'est vous
étiez présente lors d'un événement
organisé hier pour la semaine de
l'industrie
il y avait une visite d'edf à chatou à
destination des lycéennes
alors pourquoi à destination de filles
uniquement alors parce qu'en fait en
terminale scientifique il se trouve
qu'il ya environ autant de filles que de
garçons et malheureusement il n'y a que
10 15 % de ces jeunes filles alors
qu'elles sont souvent meilleurs que
leurs collègues masculins qui
s'orientent vers des carrières
scientifiques et techniques comme la
formation d'ingénieur en particulier qui
vous l'expliquez comment alors on
explique d'abord le voka peut être
ingénieur n'est pas très sexy
c'est ça fait un peu industriel ça fait
un peu sale mécanique alors que en fait
derrière le mot d'ingénieurs ya pas un
métier mais il ya vraiment des dizaines
voire des centaines de métiers
différents qui sont tous passionnants et
puis voilà le métier d'ingénieur ouvre
sur sur plein de possibilités pour sa
carrière alors poursuivre je vous
propose justement de regarder ce
reportage en images au beau milieu de ce
laboratoire hydraulique un groupe de
lycéennes écouteurs sur les oreilles
elles suivent attentivement le guide un
salarié d'edf qui leur dit tout sur son
métier
cette visite un peu particulière s'est
déroulée ce mercredi aux complices edf
de chatou une initiative de
l'association elles bougent pour
promouvoir les métiers de l'industrie
auprès des filles
on ne sait pas forcément ce qu'on
voulait faire à la base et donc du coup
ça nous a ouvert l'esprit sur le métier
découvrir les métiers mais aussi prendre
goût pour cela des techniciennes et
ingénieurs de l'industrie étaient
présentes et les ont accompagnés tout au
long de la journée et a priori le
message est plutôt bien passé
elle est marraine et nous on dit faut
être forte faut s'imposer donc on va
essayer de les faire au mieux changement
de décor la visite se poursuit au poste
de supervision radioprotection florence
unes des marraines accompagne ce groupe
elle déplore de ne faire partie que des
10% en mécanique dans sa société
côté renault par exemple du mal à
recruter des femmes sont dans les
métiers techniques
donc on se dit on va aller à la source
on dire femmes en mai dirigez-vous aussi
sur les métiers techniques
y'a rien de tabou fin un peu cassé des
baies stéréotypes des stéréotypes
qu'elle bouge cherche à dépasser car
actuellement les femmes sont encore
sous-représentées dans ce secteur
les femmes sont environ 27% dans les
effectifs
des écoles d'ingénieurs et elle
représente 17% dans dans l'industrie ça
veut dire qu'il ya une perte en ligne
sérieuses et c'est bien dommage car ce
sont des secteurs qui emploient un
secteur qui emploie principalement des
ingénieurs dans les yvelines l'industrie
représente 19% de l'activité
donc le but de cette opération était
principalement de faire découvrir des
métiers assez jeune à des jeunes filles
finalement c'est aussi méconnus des
jeunes garçons oui absolument manque
d'ingénieurs en france donc ça soit des
filles et des garçons
donc c'est aussi important pour de faire
passer ses messages vis-à-vis des
garçons aussi le message c'est qu'il y a
des choses intéressantes à faire dans
l'industrie qu'est ce qu'il vous plaît
particulièrement bas en fait on s'ennuie
jamais quand on est ingénieur en
l'ingénieur il conçoit l'avenir et qu'on
soit le futur il conçoit des choses qui
existeront dans la rue demain
après-demain et
et d'autres choses et c'est ça qui est
passionnant et puis on peut travailler
dans des domaines très différents dans
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire dont vous
avez justement voilà justement qu'est ce
qui vous a attiré vers ces professions
là parce que vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure que la nappe et vous avez bien
souligné que les filles et les femmes
étaient peu intéressé vous en tant que
femme qu'est ce qui vous intéressait
pourquoi vous êtes parti dans cette voie
professionnelle
bah en fait j'aimais bien les matières
scientifiques bon j'ai un papa ingénieur
donc ça un peu ça m'a un peu orienté et
puis effectivement j'ai commencé dans
l'énergie sur les chantiers ensuite j'ai
fait beaucoup d'informatique et encore
j'ai changé là je suis plutôt côté
gestion j'ai fait ça dans le pétrole
dans le dans l'aéronautique et la dans
l'automobile donc voilà et je me suis
jamais ennuyé et c'est ça que c'est le
message que je veux faire passer aux
jeunes c'est voilà c'est un métier qui
permet de faire plein plein de choses
qu'on sait et qui rouge et qui embauche
et qui paye bien aussi c'est un faux lui
mentionné c'est important de le dire
aussi oui alors donc qui embauchent
pourtant la dernière étude de
l'observatoire de la cci de france
indique 392 mille emplois dans
l'industrie en ile de france ce qui
représente deux fois moins qu'il ya 20
ans pour cette action donc d'elle bougea
et df pascal faure directeur général de
la compétitivité au sein du ministère du
redressement productif est passée en fin
de journée on a profité du coup pour lui
demander pourquoi on observait une telle
perte de vitesse dans le secteur on
écoute vous savez l'industrie se
transforme ça c'est ça a été de tout
temps et ça continuera comme ça ce qu'il
faut c'est toujours avoir les nouvelles
industries qui se développe et qui
prennent la place des plus anciennes
alors après il ya d'autres phénomènes
qui apparaissent les zones urbaines sont
pas forcément très favorable aux eaux
au sein d'industries lourdes c'est
plutôt les services qui se développe
donc quand on dit que l'industrie a
reculé fort que le service lui a
progressé donc au bout du bout il ya
toujours des emplois alors pour pascal
fort justement l'activité s'est reportée
sur les services parfois il s'agit même
de services pour les entreprises de
l'industrie mais chelle et là vous avez
donc peut-être peu de créations
d'entreprises industrielles
mais est-ce que vous avez finalement des
personnes issues de ce secteur qui
viennent vous voir pour créer leur
propre entreprise dans d'autres domaines
oui oui bien sûr notamment avec
l'augmentation du chômage des cadres
ces profils qu'on a de plus en plus dans
les porteurs de projets de création
d'entreprises qui viennent nous voir et
c'est vrai que ces personnes là peuvent
envisager ce des projets venir de
l'industrie ou peut-être envisager aussi
de tels projets alors donc on va quand
même relativiser le ce point noir
puisque l'île de france reste la
première région industrielle de france
avec 380 12000 emplois et les yvelines
font figure de bonne élève puisque dans
l'emploi industriel dont qui a chuté
dans toute la région
c'est en yvelines dans les yvelines que
la baisse a été la plus faible - 14 - 14
% contre - 64% à paris ce qui est quand
même relativement important 14% du
département voilà donc autres événements
que nous avons suivis pour cette semaine
de l'industrie c'est un cv dating au
pôle emploi de guyancourt des
entreprises étaient invités et des
conseillers l'arabe et sélectionner les
offres en fonction de leurs demandes
on regarde le sujet alors que le chômage
s'envole ces derniers mois atteignant
les 7 % dans les yvelines des
entreprises industrielles recruter peine
à trouver des collaborateurs l'antenne
pôle emploi cadres de guyancourt a
décidé de profiter de la semaine de
l'industrie pour organiser ce jeudi un
rendez vous afin de cibler au mieux les
besoins de ces sociétés
au programme analyse conjointe des cv et
explications dans le détail des
compétences recherchées l'antre on
travaille sur quasiment de la dentelle
ou les recrutements sont plus
compliquées ont gravi par des approches
de compétence on travaille aussi avec
les employeurs pour rechercher d'autres
profils dans les profils seniors ou des
profils un peu moins qualifiés exemple
avec ce recruteurs venus pour le compte
d'une société informatique dont la
croissance serait en moyenne de 20% par
an simplement on a du mal à trouver du
mal à trouver les bonnes compétences que
ce soit au niveau commercial puisque
nous recrutons des des chargés
d'affaires et aussi au niveau technique
nous recherchons peut-être plus des
moutons à cinq pattes c'est peut-être un
petit peu la difficulté
impossible encore de dresser le bilan de
l'opération mais un constat déjà il
faudra multiplier à l'avenir ce genre
d'opération maintenant le pôle emploi 1
une cvthèque diffuse des annonces des
annonces qui sont qui sont
systématiquement renouvelés
donc c'est vraiment important de d'être
présent et d'établir ce partenariat
j'insiste mais c'est vraiment important
alors on le voit c'est parfois difficile
de trouver finalement des salariés de
d'embaucher des gens vous l'expliquez
comment ces difficultés au procès il
faut trouver les bonnes compétences
il faut il donc il faut que les gens
soient formés donc soit il faut déjà
également attirer les jeunes vers ces
formations
et puis éventuellement reconvertir des
gens qui viendraient d'autres secteurs
plus difficultés pour se réorienter vers
ces filières qui embauchent et et qui
offre des perspectives intéressantes
mais il faut aussi former tout de même
les gens il faut que les gens soient
forts on peut former les gens en interne
aussi sur ce type de profession oui mais
si on pas dans les compétences bien sûr
on
il existe en interne dans des grosses
sociétés des programmes de reconversion
on peut passer une prise de risque aussi
peut-être pour l'entreprise aussi même
si elle manque de collaborateurs avaient
parié sur un collaborateur futur
potentiellement qui aura les compétences
qui va réussir à suivre la formation
mais s'est pas jouée d'avancé
oui m'enfin je pense que c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde de
l'entreprise et de
et du salarié d'augmenter ses
compétences de faire des choses
différentes
et puis c'est toujours intéressant
d'apprendre je prends des professions
qui évolue alors évitons les compétences
d oser se lancer alors la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et est
partenaire de cet événement à pôle
emploi
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de
bernard hagège le premier vice président
de la chambre et spécialistes de
l'industrie on écoute son interview
bernard ajaj la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie participent à cette semaine
de l'industrie pour vous c'était une
évidence
écoutez c'est la troisième édition il y
avait aucune raison pour nous de de
cesser de participer à cette
manifestation d'autant que les tutelles
son ministère l'éducation nationale et
lyster du redressement productif
c'est une action que nous menons bien
évidemment au service de nos entreprises
qui ont besoin d'embaucher des gens avec
des qualifications y compris pour les
domaines de l'industrie
raison pour laquelle nous avons
poursuivi nous poursuivons en tout cas
notre action aux côtés des pouvoirs
publics
alors cet accent justement ce qu'elle
forme s'est déroulé tel quel événement
alors y d'abord rappelé peut-être
qu'elle est la cible grand public les
enseignants et surtout les jeunes
acquis auprès de qui en tout cas il faut
dans la mesure du possible pouvoir
susciter des vocations
quand on parle de l'industrie on pense
toujours tout de suite à des métiers
difficiles
or il en est strictement rien changé aux
folles l'immense diversité des
professions de l'industrie que nous
connaissons est il nécessaire de
rappeler que les partenaires les
yvelines est le premier département
industriel de l'île de france
donc le but c'est aussi d'inciter les
jeunes à se tourner vers l'industrie
absolue brand une nombre de métiers de
l'industrie malheureusement ne sont pas
suffisamment valorisée et dieu sait s'il
y a beaucoup à faire en la matière alors
justement sur les événements donc à leur
destination
ça sera surtout des visites
d'entreprises alors il ya plusieurs aux
actions qui sont qui sont déclinées
durant cette semaine de l'industrie
bien sûr visites d'entreprises ça paraît
effectivement une évidence puisque aller
au devant
pour un jeune visiter une entreprise par
exemple tri postal est une entreprise de
tests d'équipements aéronautiques ou de
mécanique
ce sont des domaines dont on parle qu'on
dont on entend parler mais que l'on n'a
pas l'occasion de voir in situ de la
même manière il ya d'autres actions qui
ont lieu avec le partenariat avec l'anpe
par exemple si la vocation de chambre de
commerce n'est pas la création d'emplois
évidemment mais les entreprises pour
fonctionner elles ont besoin de ces
emplois est bien évidemment toute
entreprise qui se développe c'est de
l'emploi créé justement cet événement
c'est un cv dating donc il y aura lieu
au pôle emploi de guyancourt est ce
qu'il y a vraiment dû
des emplois dans ces domaines et bonjour
je crois que le drame entre guillemets
et donc en quelque sorte c'est que en
effet on a beaucoup de jeunes sans
emploi et en même temps il ya beaucoup
d'emplois non pourvus c'est une c'est un
gros souci
justement la chambre de commerce fait le
lien entre les entreprises demandeurs et
et bien sûr les npe qui ont besoin d'eux
pour d'apporter de l'emploi je veux dire
aux citoyens c'est parce qu'ils
concernent qui s'est plus des postes et
donc de techniciens de cadres et coûteux
aujourd'hui dans les postes à pourvoir
pratiquement 20% d'entre eux sont des
postes de cadre dans l'industrie au sens
large
rappelons aussi que les services à
l'industrie c'est aussi dans l'industrie
mais bien sûr et souvent c'est c'est un
petit peu occulté ce fait pas partie des
statistiques ce qui est dommage mais en
réalité ça fait partie effectivement de
l'activité industrielle d'un département